I feel so close welcome to 5 lambda if
hi what are you doing
we don't hit drinks in here your parties
must suck no we don't throw parties here
in the United States sororities are not
allowed to throw parties in their own
houses only frat scam these are the
sexist restrictive system hormones our
sorority that imported the way that we
want to what's the name of our sorority
Kappa Kappa nu
welcomes who are a sorority Kappa nu
we're never gonna sell out half of a
sorority living next door what are we
gonna do baby it's not that bad girls
are usually quiet don't really take hard
drugs and they're much smarter no I
killed a girl we need somebody who can
relate to stupid young people
hey neighbors let's shut this [ __ ] down
theme song mark Melinda plexi some
disguises everyone you look like a
psychopath it's a clown man people love
clowns alright stop doing that in
America pattern antal our sorority I got
an idea we go with the air bag trick
that's not gonna work if it worked with
guys why would it work for girls guys
are idiot it's a little hard to call
cops without a phone give us that back
no oh it's called cork dumbass those
girls are out of control they're using
their sexuality as a weapon
you don't understand that there's no i'
in sororities there's two actually
there's actually there's just one no
that's a y no in the middle that's a no
s o i.t i.t
sorority that's how you spell it
you think that titty is silent oh oh
that I'm gonna put a pillow every enough
you're like choking or something what
it's like a new sexy thing noise this
telling why wake up oh no I'll just be
quiet
Oh
I came to get you dude no you're not
freaking out about having a second kid
three how do you keep finding mommy
filled oh we really got to gather some
dolls doesn't miss pinky want some tea
where you didn't really sell yet in 30
days if everything goes well you close
assuming leather fraternity doesn't move
in next door you're gonna be fine what
the [ __ ] is going on over there
hi we're neighbors welcome to our
sorority
I can't believe a [ __ ] sorority move
next door I can't even talk to those
girls nothing
what number hmm nah do babies not that
bad
early usually quiet family take hard
drugs and they're much smarter
Oh No I kill the girl the buyers could
come by at any moment and see their 20
psychopathic teenager next four we need
somebody who can relate to stupid young
people I shut this [ __ ] down that's
right I'm switching sides
theme song bark my let the Black Sea so
if we steal their stash they won't be
able to pay the rent
what's the plan I'm gonna dance just few
dancing is enough to distract the entire
sorority do you want me to go up with
you handle American Chinese mantle our
sorority you know you kids listen to
celebrities you called our parents dad
what is this what happened to my little
girl
it's really not a big deal this is a
very big deal it's on oh you turned it
on come on out back Olivia
well if we turn it on we can
this isn't working you're only making
them sexier it's a little hard to call
cops without a phone
give us that back me up Oh it's called
Korg dumbass [ __ ] phone
[ __ ] gotta get out of here
that's our way I the blast from this
airbag will propel you go straight
through that vent time to save my family
don't work car drugs and they're much
smarter no I killed a girl